Hey, Vsauce. Michael here. And are you still
doing things in the real world? C'mon, I mean,
why flip a coin when you could justflipacoin.com?
Every time you refresh the page, it flips
again. Of course, there are plenty of other
things you can Do Online Now, Guys.
For instance, have you ever wondered "Am I
Awesome?" Well, ask the Internet.
Go to amiawesome.com -
it never lies. Earn your awesomeness like
Monstewn by playing The Wiki Game against
opponents from all over the world. Here I
am clicking links to race from the U.S. Constitution
to South India. I had a rough patch there
in the middle, but I got by in a squeaker.
The constellations in the sky have looked
the way they do since the ancient people gave
them names, but they are still fleeting because
our Earth moves, and the solar system moves,
and the galaxy is moving all through space,
they won't always look the same. This website
shows you what will happen to them in the
future. For instance, 70,000 years from today,
standing on Earth, the Big Dipper will look like this.
If Cosmonauts explore the cosmos, and you
explore the Internet, that makes your an Internaught
and Internaughts love confrontation, specifically,
thedisagreeinginternet.com. Begin from here
and the internet will constantly
be shaking its head at you.
In Pyro, you aim flaming balls to start fires
and burn things. But to test your wits, try
The Impossible Quiz. Multiple choice questions
that make you think "can a match box?" "No,
but a tin can."
The Amaster15 pointed me towards this incredible
depository of giant images. Like, really,
really giant.
Following the rules is safe and easy, for
instance, "deliver." Ok, done. But, when a
level says "disobey,"don't do what is says.
AuzzieZiggy recommends Motherload where you
play as a machine that can burrow but also
jump pretty well. Make money collecting rock
to upgrade and don't forget to refuel.
Stealing the Diamond lets you make choices
and see how they pan out. Be careful and
creative.
For a string of bizarre clips, thebest404pageever.com
always offers a pleasant surprise.
But take a break and relax with 2playstationnetwork
and play in the sand, because thisissand.com.
And oh, look, Amy Poehler has a channel on
YouTube with lots of different kinds of stuff,
including her answering your questions while
she lies on a bed or sits in a shower. It's
for Smart Girls, but yes,
there is a weekly Boy Minute.
TheChelengo asks you to test out passwords
at howsecureismypassword.net. The site estimates
and displays how quickly a PC could guess
your password. Does that make you nervous?
Well, Hissandpixels is here to calm you down
with thenicestplaceontheinter.net. It's nothing
but a never-ending parade of fullscreen videos
of people hugging you.
Writer's block? Well be like techonyoursix
and generate yourself some plots. This site
randomly creates scenarios to get you thinking.
RangerForceful recommends Last Square Standing,
which is super simple but gets tough quick.
Avoid touching anything for as long as you can.
Pointer Pointer watches your pointer and then
pulls a photo from its giant reservoir in
which someone points to where your pointer is.
Finally, SirFatSug asked hasthelargehadroncolliderdestroyedtheworldyet.com.
Phew, ok, it looks like we're good for now,
but let's periodically check on this to make
sure the world is still together and if it
is, or even if it isn't...
As always,
thanks for watching.